aquí
[Música]
tienes miedo a la inteligencia
artificial
porque parece que deberían tiene todos
los ingredientes necesarios es un tema
complejo lleno de fórmulas matemáticas
que nada nadie sabe explicar muy bien
grandes empresas californianas y
asiáticas están invirtiendo millones de
dólares personajes públicos nos dice que
será el fin de la humanidad
y hollywood nos muestra con lujos de
detalles cómo será ese fin
es un debate fascinante e importante
pero me parece que tanta preocupación
por el fin de la raza humana hace que no
veamos peligros más concretos que ya
están ocurriendo
yo dirijo un grupo de investigación cuyo
objetivo es enseñar a las computadoras a
entender ya generar el lenguaje humano y
desde ese punto de vista yo veo
consecuencias negativas que ya están
ocurriendo hoy en día
hoy me gustaría encontrarte cuáles son
esas consecuencias cómo llegamos a ellas
y lo que vos puedes hacer al respecto
pero antes quisiera que se imaginen un
mundo un mundo donde las computadoras
podrían entender todas las matices de
nuestro lenguaje de lo que hablamos
en un mundo así los diferentes idiomas
ya no serían una barrera para la
comunicación los que trabajan con
extranjeros los que han viajado afuera
saben de lo que hablo para mí es una
realidad cotidiana yo nací en brasil
estudie me crié en alemania estudié en
argentina y ahora vivo en francia
trabajando para una empresa coreana
hablando inglés
todos los días me frustro porque no
encuentro las palabras que expresan lo
que yo quiero decir
ahora el mundo este que yo los invito a
que se imaginen va más allá un mundo de
las computadoras entienden lo que
decimos sería un mundo donde en
principio no habría más necesidad de
pantalla de teclado de mouse nunca más
habría que llenar un formulario cada uno
de nosotros tendría un agente con el
personal con el que podríamos debatir
cualquier tema y que nos daría la
información exacta que necesitamos en el
momento justo
claro estamos lejos muy lejos de este
mundo que los invito a que se imaginen
los primeros intentos por acercarse a
esta edición fueron en los años 50
cuando un lingüista norteamericano
llamado chomsky revolucionó su campo al
proponer usar modelos matemáticos para
estructurar el lenguaje
y los la primera generación de métodos
de inteligencia artificial tenían en
común esta idea de encontrar la
estructura perfecta o buena suficiente
que al mismo tiempo pueda capturar esta
complejidad del lenguaje y al mismo
tiempo ser codificado por una
computadora para ser manipulada por ella
hubo varios intentos varios varios
propuestas y cuando alguno de estos
estaban a punto y funcionaban en las
situaciones controlados en los
laboratorios los investigadores
empezaron a aplicarlo afuera del
laboratorio
y fue ahí que pasó algo tremendo
estos métodos no funcionaban
no funcionaba porque el lenguaje que
estamos hablando que hablamos nosotros
está lleno de errores de excepciones de
malentendidos de sobreentendidos de
frases mal hechas
ningún método formal logras capturar
toda esta complejidad del lenguaje
nuestro
fue ahí que entró una segunda generación
de métodos de inteligencia artificial
cuyo ingrediente principal esta vez era
el uso de las probabilidades estas
probabilidades le daban una una le
asignaba en una noción de incertidumbre
a las diferentes interpretaciones
posibles de una frase y un método de
optimización calculaba cuál es la
interpretación la más probable
estas probabilidades se exprimen como
miles incluso millones de parámetros
internos números internos que hay que
chequear que hay que poner y ninguna
persona es capaz de hacer eso a mano
entonces más y más se empezó a usar un
método que consistía en que la
computadora por sí mismo aprenda cuáles
son los valores ideales para estos
parámetros internos y la idea que si tú
ves que los aprendas por si mismo viendo
muchos datos existentes la ayuda en la
siguiente en su póngale que ustedes
quieren a enseñarle a la computadora las
diferentes acepciones de la palabra
banco
podemos estar hablando de un banco de
peces podemos estar hablando de
institución financiera de un depósito de
tejidos humanos incluso de un verbo como
este banco cómo funciona estos métodos
es que yo les doy muchas frases que
contiene la palabra banco a la
computadora junto con una pequeña
anotación utiliza cuál de todas las
acepciones me estoy refiriendo en esta
frase la idea el método de optimización
ajusta estos parámetros internos y el
día de mañana lo de una frase nueva que
contiene la palabra banco
el método le asigna una noción de
incertidumbre a las diferentes
acepciones posibles y deduce cuál es la
excepción a más probable
esta misma idea es la que se usa para
traducir el español al chino es la que
se usa para crear un chat college las
que se gusta para determinar cuáles son
las emociones entre una frase o para
determinar cuál es el gusto favorito de
lado en twitter en esta temporada
ahora
esta receta de tanto fijarse en los
datos empezó a volverse cada vez más
útil porque las computadoras se volvían
más poderosas porque había más datos
anotados gracias a internet sobre todo y
porque los métodos se ponían a punto y
cada vez se necesitaban menos de
estructuras prediseñadas y nos podíamos
fiar más y más en esta idea de usar
datos anotados de los cuales la
computadora podría aprender
esto trajo algunas consecuencias y yo
quisiera mencionar dos que son
importantes para nuestro debate sobre
los peligros de la inteligencia
artificial
la primera las consecuencias es que
estos métodos de segunda generación son
muy pocos robustos y los datos sobre los
que tiene que predecir son distintos que
los datos sobre los que fue entrenado
son como el amigo que alguno de ustedes
tiene que está convencido que la mejor
selección argentina era de la copa
américa 91 y no solamente no quiero
hablar de ningún otro deporte sino se
niega a hablar del mundial pasado con
las computadoras es parecida incluso es
peor porque los computadores que se
niegan a hablar de un tema sobre el que
no están seguros sino que dicen
cualquier cosa
en mi grupo usamos un método de
traducción automática para traducir
descripciones de restaurant y cada vez
que encontraba la palabra francesa cast
lo traducía como mapa que una excepción
posible de hecho es la más probable en
un contexto genérico pero no el nuestro
contexto que estábamos hablando de
restaurantes donde el menú sería la
traducción correcta
es esta es una de las razones
principales por las que yo no creo en un
escenario donde de golpe las
computadoras se vuelvan adquiere una
inteligencia sobrehumana -aseguran-
conscientes de sí mismos y decidan que
no necesitamos de todos estos mis pelos
y los podemos eliminar
para lograr una inteligencia así no
solamente los métodos actuales no nos
van a llevar sino que ni siquiera
sabemos qué tipo de herramientas
necesitaríamos los métodos actuales son
como una escalera una escalera alta que
estoy estamos escalando que nos permite
acceder a muchos problemas distintos que
son los diferentes pisos que ustedes ven
acá
pero sabemos que no nos van a llevar a
esta inteligencia consciente de sí mismo
para llegar a esto ministerios como dijo
una herramienta distinta un ascensor un
helicóptero o simplemente una escalera
más alta pero no lo sabemos
problema como dice el investigador pedro
domingos no es que las computadoras se
vuelvan inteligentes y empiecen a
dominar el mundo
el problema
es que las computadoras son tontas pero
ya lo dominan al mundo
ya no dominan porque ya están afectando
nuestras decisiones cotidianas sin que
nos demos cuenta
deciden qué clase de noticia leemos y
qué clase de estas noticias no leemos
deciden si podemos x tenemos derecho a
tener un seguro de salud cuánto hay que
pagar el derecho de la el seguro del
auto cuánto tiempo vamos a estar preso
cómo nos van a evaluar en nuestro
trabajo
y esta y esta receta de fiarse tanto en
datos anotados preexistentes es como
decirle a nuestros hijos cuando estamos
cansados de que nos hagan tanta pregunta
mirá acá está el diario anda leerlo y
vas a ver cómo funciona el mundo o aún
peor anda leer los comentarios de
youtube y vas a ver cómo se tiene que
hablar las personas civilizadas
fue así como las computadoras
aprendieron que un gerente es
necesariamente un hombre o enfermería es
una profesión ejercicio solamente por
mujeres
o qué frases como soy judío hay un negro
en mi patio conllevan una anotación una
emoción negativa o de miedo
si las computadoras van a aprender de
nuestras huellas digitales también van a
aprender todos los prejuicios que
tenemos los humanos
entonces qué es lo que vos puedes hacer
al respecto
quiero dejar dos ideas y las dos son
super simples
de hecho la primera a mí personalmente
no me conviene mucho yo durante años le
he dicho a las personas que se me
acercaban porque tenían algún problema
con su computadora mira la computadora
solamente hace lo que se le dice si no
hace lo que vos querés es porque vos le
estás diciendo algo equivocado
a partir de hoy el software que usamos
es cada vez más aprendido y no diseñado
así que mantengan el espíritu crítico
abierto traten de entender que lo que
está pasando hagan preguntas y no duden
en quejarse
en segundo lugar toda obra sin algo de
su creador
por muchos de los que trabajamos
inteligencia artificial somos bastante
parecidos a mi hombres blancos de una
situación económica estable
si todos pensamos igual ni siquiera nos
vamos a dar cuenta que las computadoras
están codificando algún tipo de
prejuicio que tenemos
así que por favor si vos o alguien de tu
entorno quiere estudiar programación no
le digas no eso solamente para geeks
ahora las mujeres no hacen eso los
programadores tienen una influencia
enorme sobre el mundo en que vivimos y
necesitamos gente de toda diversidad y
de trasfondo posible
la inteligencia artificial
es como cualquier otra herramienta
creada descubierta por el hombre puede
ser usado para hacer un tremendo bien un
mal de facto y es a nosotros de vigilar
sobre su uso
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y